great to have you in studio I'm just
curious what you get on the street when
you're walking in New York what do they
yell out to you Oh Madea Madea Madea
Tyler Madea so yeah yeah I deal with
that a lot I'm wondering if you go back
to Larry Johnson when Larry did
grandmama do you remember those
commercials it was a long time ago yeah
yeah I do remember but Madea is not the
Madea is more of your mom right oh yes
Larry was wearing that he was the
Grandmamma Grandmamma yeah yeah no it's
my cross between my mother and my aunt
banner these are the funniest women I
know you don't want to run into them in
an alley late in the midnight you know
they'll take you down they'll take you
down now do you have to get mom and
grandma's approval of some of the humor
yeah my mom before she passed she loved
it but but Madea is the PG version of
those women no there's their straight n
c---seventeen man they don't stop what
happens what was it like to put on a
dress dress is a woman that first time
it was it was really scary me I had an
actress that didn't show up at a show
this is a true story and Madea was born
in that moment so I had to go onstage
and do the Madea lines and Airlines and
it just got bigger and bigger every time
I get up and walk across the stage the
audience will be lapsim what are they
laughing at that time I said I got this
big ass in the back bouncing all over
the place man it's been it's been a lot
it's been a lot of fun to see the
artists reaction but I freaking hate it
you do hate oh my god man that costume
and that wig and if I if somebody told
me years ago that this thing was gonna
go on almost 20 years I might have had a
different I wouldn't play the character
or something nothing you got another one
coming out Madea and in their funeral
the funeral yeah they're coming out
because people keep coming I tell them I
say as soon as you guys see this move it
is so broad it's bad
she is dead quicker than anything I'm
telling you she doesn't die in the
funeral one no she doesn't die spoiler
alert yes she buries some other people
in the field well who knows if if this
movie don't do well see when did you get
famous am i yeah you guys were just
talking about that like Ryan Reynolds
like that's that's famous would you want
that
no no I'm - I'm too low-key for that I
like I like to be able to kind of blend
in which is hard being six six
but what I like to try to blend in but
no no it's too much it's too much but
people know the name yeah they know that
it but that's enough yeah that's enough
that's enough because behind the scenes
in all the work is where my focus is the
business side of it opening the studio
down in Atlanta I bought Fort McPherson
army base and turned it into a studio
with 12 sound stages and it's it's
coming along great I'm really excited
about it how great is it to not be in
Los Angeles oh that's that's that's
pretty wonderful man that's that's
really wonderful I'm not a I'm not a la
guy at all not a la guy at all I have a
house there but I go for business and
get out is I'm a guy likes yeah I want
to be around more trees than people but
at your sign what are you six six one
six six what what's that
six six but wait - yes please please
they're 15 I'm actually 280 280 yeah
280 and you never played never played
had a secure had a resentment for man
because I had asthma the kidney were so
good my mother would come outside and
she seemed out there playing football
was my sports career it was over wow
that's pretty good though yeah that mom
was mom is protecting you yeah you're
also the biggest guy though out there
aren't you oh and you know in the
backyard yeah completely
yeah but I'm from New Orleans so there
were a lot of big people and that's
still a big people in New World well
could you do a movie based on your
childhood oh wow everything that's
involved with it
whoa that would be really intense I
don't know nothing too much there it's
there's there's not there's a lot there
but but I would be afraid to leave
bodies in the street if so to speak just
there to tell the true story there are
people who are still around who would be
affected greatly so I'll just save it
for a book one day how about if you did
it as a comedy hmm it wasn't pretty
can you direct yourself I know with
Madea you're doing that yeah but how
difficult is that and can somebody
suggest something to you that
maybe they saw that you didn't oh
absolutely especially when I'm when I'm
directing myself with this the funniest
thing though it's standing there that
day I'm constantly trying to direct
people and tell them okay voice okay I
need to camera over here bring the line
of the Lighting's a little off and all
its crews looking at me like is he
serious like ya ever gone out in costume
no no that's just too weird with I don't
even dress up for Halloween because the
whole the whole time I'm doing these
movies and things like that I don't want
I don't want to see a costume how about
being an actor when you're not directing
mmm like gone girl hunger I loved that
man I loved working with David Fincher
he's brilliant he does 50 million takes
a each each time but I didn't understand
it at what he was doing but then I
started watching how what a master he is
at seeing things like he he'll do 20
takes based on the reflection of a glass
in the corner until he gets it right I
don't want that many options when I'm
when I'm editing I'll give me two can
you second-guess the director when
you're just the actor in it I wouldn't
do that just out of respect for their
process I wouldn't if I'm gonna sign on
to do somebody else's project I'm gonna
totally surrender and let them let them
lead the way in your head though could
you be second yes but it also helps you
I'm gonna guess have a different
perspective when you're directing oh I
went to that was like going to school
for me man it was so great I got a movie
coming out next called acrimony that I
borrowed a lot of learned a lot on gone
girl and I borrowed a lot of that and
took it with me from him ended up it's
called sampling right can you sample off
of somebody else it depends it depends
on if it's a Motown song enough um when
you did you never hear somebody saying I
sampled off that movie it's always
taught music ya know it's soon when I
say that I mean it's it's the style and
the paying attention to it and the
lighting and the feel in the mood and
things like that I was like whoa okay I
get it I see what they're doing do you
like comedy or drama and they both have
their place but right now I think for me
the comedy is so important because all
this going on in this country man yeah
all of our pastimes everything we're
trying to get to escape is
there's becoming so political so I just
wanted to do a movie it's like 100
minutes of just stupid silly fun don't
think about anything just go laugh and
have a good time so you make no
apologies with that for no not being a
silly movie yeah yeah no it's I'm not
trying to make sure Liz Liz this is
exactly what I'm ready to make the
critics are like what was he thinking be
so serious Tyler Perry's new movie boo
to Madea Halloween hits theaters next
Friday October 20th do I have to see the
other madea's to understand this no no
you just you just have to go in get a
joint a drink I don't think you can get
joints at the movie theater though
[Music]
especially with the comedy I think that
would help you did you grow up with a
comedy movie that stayed with you or
said boy that's that kind of sparked
something in me
oh listen to me Jerry Lewis was
hysterical man I see him all the time
just this other things that he would do
was was so funny Steve Martin and
Richard Pryor
though those guys though that's the kind
of movies that grew up on just laugh at
the jerk I'm a man of smooth were so
funny so funny I missed those missed
those kind of movies did you want to be
a stand-up comedian no no I never had a
dis no interest no no I fell into this
thing I was watching The Oprah Show yes
big black man was watching and she said
it was cathartic to write things down
and I started writing and and I I was
using different characters name and a
friend found it he said man this is a
really good play and I thought a play
okay well maybe I should go start seeing
someplace so I couldn't afford to go to
the theater so I would wait to
intermission when everybody would come
out to smoke and I would follow them
back into the theater so these critics
would say something about his movies
they always seem like it's just one act
and that's why I was just learning from
the one
what was that like when was Oprah a
phone call the first time or was it in
in person it was a phone call on April
Fool's Day to be on her show and I
thought I was being you know honey poor
fool yeah yeah so then I show up and you
know we do the show and in 2007 is when
she invited me to party she was having a
call the legends ball and that's when
she and I became friends okay but what's
that like I mean you're walking in
you're some guy sitting at home and your
underwear eaten Funyuns or something
watching Oprah absolutely absolutely
cloth batteries and all but uh but nope
I love for you no no it was really
surreal just going in there and having a
conversation with her and this somebody
who I admired who looked like she could
be a relative of mine and and really
inspired me through some really hard
times I thought wow that's pretty
awesome all right welcome back you live
in Atlanta
you grew up in New Orleans yeah yeah I
don't know if you're a Saints fan or a
found content and save this okay it's
called a tease Tyler okay you about
Colin Kaepernick as well and going to
the fight when you went to do to go
Mayweather yeah yeah I'm saving it it's
a tease Tyler Perry presents the Dan
Patrick show so rap jeopardy pretty give
Tyler are you up on the rap game do you
know lyrics me no you don't know oh okay
hi fritzy give Tyler a lyric I'll give
I'll go in with with Slick Rick and
Dougie fresh where he goes give me a
second they got on the D train at what
Street Dougie fresh got on the D train
at what Street ooh tough one mmm I have
no idea got on the G train at 250 so a
pretty girl so so what's that beside her
then she went wrong it was too
I just full intro here Tyler Perry
big-time actor writer director producer
well no we weren't sure how to act you
wait like everybody was like we gotta
clean up around Tyler Perry's coming in
I know Oprah's watching so always yeah
Tyler Perry's new movie boo to Madea
Halloween hits theaters next Friday
October 20th and secretly doesn't want
you to like the movie so he can stop
dressing got a Madea funeral movie
coming up and and then one after that
I'm gonna cook on all these superheroes
though get them all in there Iron Man
versus Madea let's do it let's do it
I hope Marvel's Robert Downey jr. versus
Madea I'm going Madea we just ruined
that franchise I love it all right a
couple of things you live in Atlanta
yeah but you grew up in New Orleans yeah
Saints fan I'm a Salkin fan okay on the
front of my Jersey the Saints in the
back of Falcons when I'm going to that
game we're both playing yeah that's what
we do where'd you watch the Superbowl
where did I watch the Superbowl I can't
remember did you watch the Super Bowl
because the Falcons aren't sure where
they were Super Bowl Wow
did that hurt a little bit are you
invested that much with the Falcons that
it would actually bother you for me I
don't one of those people died you know
just for me it's just the past time just
released you went to the fight
Mayweather McGregor yeah I'm a part
owner in the UFC oh yeah so you know who
I was rooting for yeah hey no kidding
yeah but it was a really good fight
really really good fight but do you
understand like their showman yeah like
there's something about that way we were
fortunate and I'm older than you but
Muhammad Ali was a showman who said it
and then did it right a lot of these
showman now say it but don't necessarily
yes that was a show that was a show from
from the time they did their first in
way into all the way to the end it's
pretty awesome could Conor McGregor be
an action hero yeah I think so I think
so I don't know what he'd be but yeah
because it I mean he has a look about
him like he's more of a villain I think
he'd be better villain yeah but you yeah
but you could cast him as a villain hey
man I do Madea movies that I'm not doing
Marvel I mean but you okay but do you
want to do something that what would
shock us that you want to do what it
will be a radical change where you go
I'm going here I'm gonna play Dick
Cheney and then could just make up ever
could you do a movie on Colin Kaepernick
could you do it would you do a
documentary on Kaepernick or is there
not enough there that you would be
interest interested in something like
that
I think the documentary or the movie
should be about the movement and what's
going on yeah what what what is what a
Bidoof innate did this amazing
documentary called 13 that talks about
you know all the fighting equal rights
and equality and and all the police
brutality and just prisons the prison
systems and everything that's going on
in this country right now that need to
be addressed so so I think I think more
of the issue would be better on the
focus what do you see what do you think
when you look at these protests with
what Kaepernick has risk I get it I get
both sides I get it I get almost sounded
like Trump when I say there's good
people on both sides I know I get it in
this sense because you know this is
their platform these football players
it's their platform and they want to use
it to raise awareness and bring
attention to this police violence which
i think is very very important I think
it solves no issues by them being called
sons of [ __ ] and and
it would be a much better conversation
if they were able to sit down with the
White House and NFL players to hear both
sides I think it because I think there's
something to be said for listening to
both sides I don't think it's about
disrespect like I really really don't I
know there's no intention there to
disrespect the flag or the country and
especially the veterans so I take
offense to that because it's not that
for me now what's next though yeah with
this absolutely right and that's the key
right but but the thing is you go from
from one player kneeling to half the
team's kneeling because of the attention
that was raised by the White House which
is good in one sense because it brings
awareness to the actual issue so it I
don't know where we go from here man I
just I'm sick of the division in this
country I'm sick of I'm sick of all of
the things that we love and enjoy and
the pastimes that we have being
infiltrated with there's so much
negativity I just I'm just a little
annoyed by it all and that's why you
came up with Donald Trump's trying to
make America great you're trying to make
America laugh yeah yeah we'll make
America laugh while we're all being
great medea is there is there a topic
from Adia that you wouldn't touch how'd
you come up with a voice oh that's my
heart man that is her completely and she
and she rounds her arse at the end of
her sentence is she talking because she
thinks he's talking properly you should
see her in church where she's a hello
pastors good to see you good morn-ting
because she was serious she was serious
do you but she knows you're mocking her
right she thinks it's all flattery oh
she does yes she finds it all flattering
it's a tribute it's it's a chance
definitely a trick a deadly attribute
but I'm telling you she is the nc-17
version give me an idea of what your
days like now like what are you gonna do
after this this show this appearance
probably about 75,000 more interviews
occur between here in Miami and Atlanta
and have we've been in eight cities in
like four to five days or something and
so but that's just the promotion of the
movie but when I'm home I'm writing and
shooting the shows all day it's it's for
12 14 hour day when we're in production
yeah but how many movies have you done
18 okay I think so yeah 18 20 how many I
put TV episodes and we're at 968 now
where's it all come from and you do the
writing yeah yeah nobody's allowed to
suggest to anything no they totally can
but I but my imagination man as a kid I
was blessed with this crazy vivid
imagination nice and I still AM able to
use that to write so so it seems to work
out I ran into Charles Schultz the
peanuts creator and I played golf with
him and I at one point I felt
comfortable enough at one point I don't
know a fifth hole sixth hole and I said
you know what I had an idea and you stop
I go no no I got an idea to stop and I
go it was just something for peanut you
could no no because I I just I'd rather
you didn't tell me yeah
and I went okay shut me down either he
thought your idea sucked unless he
gathered what my personality was like in
the first four holes he said that guy's
not creative he's an idiot manage shut
me down yeah I understand that I
understand it because you know in this
business when you when you have ideas
and and you want to protect what you
have in your head and don't want to have
something from someone else or end up
being sued by someone else saying how I
create gave him that idea so yeah yeah I
understand that policy crazy he's a big
time man you big big time you got a
nickname big time Oprah's gonna call you
right after any big time can you imitate
Oprah smart guy Tyler Perry's new movie
boo - a madea Halloween he just wants to
make you laugh and he loves wearing that
costume love wear that costume
next Friday October 20th nationwide
thank you for coming thank you
absolutely he's Tyler Perry the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings
on audience